The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: So we're
very excited about this class.
And, excuse me, this
is the only time
I get you until
after spring break.
So I'm not going to--
well I'll see you, maybe,
but in terms of this class,
I come on after spring break
and then I get you for
the rest of the semester.
And so what I want to do
in the next 20 minutes
is just give you a little
preview of what's coming.
Now, did you, Professor
Wheeler, did you
talk about laptops and stuff?
So let me talk about
that for a minute.
Any of you who had me in 3012
know that, for me, what I
would prefer is that when I'm
lecturing, that you don't have
your laptops open and
you're not pulling
your sort of under the
table texting, unless--
now there is an exception.
Who knows the exception?
Can anybody remember?
Nobody actually took me
up on this last fall,
but if you really feel
so inspired by what
I'm talking about or
what we're talking about
that you need to send a
tweet and summarize it,
or you need to broadcast this
information that you're getting
in the class out to more
people to bring them in,
then that's OK.
Otherwise, I'd really
prefer it because if you
open your laptop,
what you're doing
is you're creating
a field of view
for all the people behind
you to get distracted.
Same with the phone under
the table trick, right?
A lot of people see that.
It's a little distracting.
The point of the class
is discussion, right?
So we're going to
have slides, we're
going to talk about slides,
but if you don't ask questions,
it's a lot less useful.
You won't learn as much.
So I really like
getting interrupted.
Just, like, yell out something.
I don't know.
In 3012, the key
word was "entropy."
You could yell out "entropy"
any time, and I'd turn around
and we'd talk.
Here, it could be, like,
"quantum" would be a good one,
right?
But I really want you to ask
the question when you have it,
because if we have a
discussion on the spot
about your question, that's
a learning moment, right?
That's a chance to
learn more for everyone.
So I mean, the studies are in.
I'm not just being
kind of touchy feely
about learning here.
There's a lot of
rigorous studies
about how people learn best.
And it's in those discussions
where you learn the most.
So please, interact.
Ask questions.
Now I'm going to motivate
quantum mechanics.
And how many of you have seen
quantum mechanics before?
How many of you have never
seen quantum mechanics?
It's OK.
See, the thing is, what's
going to be really--
so here's the thing.
You don't have to have
seen quantum mechanics
to feel your complete
oneness and total enjoyment
of the quantum mechanical
simulations we're going to do.
This is going to be really
exciting whether you've
seen quantum or not because
we're going to kind of start
slowly and then
we're going to learn
how to simulate the behavior
of quantum mechanics.
So what I want to do
today is just tell you
sort of why this is exciting
and why this is important.
OK?
OK, so that's what--
and I'll give you a more
detailed outline when
I come on for my part
after spring break,
but those are sort of
the highlights of what
we're going to touch on.
Now I thought that--
OK, so I think Professor Wheeler
may have shown this, right?
So did you show the computers?
Does anybody know where the
fastest computer on the planet
is?
We've gotten a
lot faster, right?
So some of these
were actually here.
The Whirlwind was here.
So you can see the number
of operations per second
has increased
dramatically, right?
Where's the fastest
computer in the world today?
Good guess.
Yeah.
Anybody know who has it?
It's Google, right?
It's Google.
And I keep emailing
them, and they
don't respond to my
emails, because I
want to get some
cycles on that machine.
But they actually need
to build power plants
for those computers.
And Professor Wheeler
showed that there's
like one little rack where your
simulations are going to go.
Well Google has like
thousands of those.
Now I thought I'd share my
own personal history here.
Has anybody seen either
of these in a museum?
This is the good old days.
We used to call it the Trash-80.
It was a couple of years ago.
But that's how I grew up, just
working on machines like this.
And then there was
this one which had
a cartridge you could put in.
You could save your
data to a tape.
OK?
Do you remember that?
No, you're too young.
Yeah.
So now, when you save data to a
tape, you literally are-- like,
you guys think about
megabytes, gigabytes.
You would save like
a 10k file and it
would take you 10 minutes, OK?
And it would have these beeps.
Anyway, someday you can
check it out in the museum.
But my favorite is the
startup screen, right?
So this one would just come
on and it would say "ready."
I like that.
Right?
So those are the old days.
OK, so Professor Wheeler
talked about this.
He talked about how
I'm not even on here.
I'm all the way down here.
Hey.
You know?
But last but not least, right?
Bottom but really
important, because we're
talking about bottom-up
materials understanding
and design, and this level--
understanding and being
able to compute
this level is going
to be important for all the
rest of the levels, right?
Now, what we're going
to talk about when
I come on in the
second half is not just
those potentials, right?
So quantum mechanics gets you
those potentials between atoms
that you can then feed into
there to there to there
to there, but it also gets
you real materials behaviors
directly that you cannot
get in any other way.
Somebody tell me a quantum
mechanical object that's
just like really quantumy.
What makes you think quantum?
Electrons, yes.
I love that.
That's another word.
If you want to say
electrons any time,
in the middle of a
sentence, say electrons.
Scream it out.
That's it, right?
Electrons are quantum
mechanical objects, right?
You really need
quantum mechanics
to know what an
electron is doing.
And it turns out that knowing
what an electron is doing
is really important for
a lot of properties, OK?
So I'm going to give you a sense
of that in this little preview
today.
OK, so we're all
the way down there.
Now there are a lot of quantum
mechanists and some of you
may recognize some
of these people.
So these are the people.
And you can tell, in contrast
to thermodynamicists,
they don't have
mutton chops, right?
And I don't know that we could
say there's a trend here.
I mean they look nice here.
A little less.
Well anyway, they look-- these
were some really smart people.
These are revolutionizing
sort of the way we
understand and view the world.
And we'll talk about what
their contributions were as we
sort of start the quantum part.
OK?
And we'll talk
about the problems.
You see, because they had
this thing for a long time.
Right?
They had classical physics
which described the world really
well.
Did we need quantum mechanics
to send people to the moon?
Turns out, no, right?
So we can do a lot
without quantum mechanics,
but there started to
become these problems
that classical mechanics
couldn't describe.
OK, and so we'll talk
about those as well.
I'm not going to
talk about them now.
But those problems
became so great,
that it just sort pushed
these great thinkers
of the time, of 100
years ago into developing
a completely new
theory for the world,
for the way we view the world.
Here's one of the funny things
about quantum mechanics.
This is a quantum
mechanical ball.
And I just threw it into a wall.
Right, and look
at what happened.
Now, we'll talk
about this later.
A quantum mechanical
ball is not a ball.
It's a spread out thing, right?
It has a probability
associated with it.
But look at what
happens there, right?
Look at this.
What's going on?
Somebody tell me
what's happening.
What is it?
Tunneling.
Now, is tunneling something that
happens in like real systems
and materials?
Yeah, you bet it does.
Electrons do it all the time.
And if you can't predict this
kind of tunneling behavior
correctly then you can't design
optoelectronic materials,
right, at least if
you want to know
what the electrons are going to
do, which is pretty important.
OK, now, it turns out
that, OK, so that's
a quantum mechanical
ball thrown into a wall.
Uh-oh, OK.
And then there is this
very simple reaction
that shows the behavior
of the electrons.
We already saw that, so
I'm going to skip that.
But so this can
be complex, right?
Things are going
like through walls.
That's weird.
Isn't that kind of weird?
I mean, that's weird.
If I throw a ball
into a wall, you
don't usually expect part
of it to keep going, right?
You expect it to bounce back.
But if I throw an electron
into that wall, some of it
will keep going, right?
And this is even weirder.
If I start mixing materials
together and reacting them,
those electrons can behave
really, really weirdly.
That's quantum mechanics.
And we'll come to feel
our enjoyment and oneness
with that weirdness.
It's really fun actually.
It's really fun to think
about how weird it is.
The nice sort of thing, and
also the really hard thing
about quantum mechanics
is that there's really
only one equation that
we're going to care about.
This is it.
Right, that's the
Schrodinger equation.
And you can see that it's just
a partial differential equation.
It shouldn't be so bad, right?
Well, so it turns out that this
equation tells us everything
that we need to know
for quantum mechanics.
It tells us about this thing.
That's the wave function.
OK, and the wave
function is the word
we use to describe that ball,
that quantum mechanical ball.
OK, it's that
weird shape, right?
And it turns out that if
we can solve that equation,
then I can get the shape of PSI.
And then I know a lot
about the quantum mechanics
of the system.
Now, here's what happens when
you try to solve that equation.
Here's this equation
written in very simple form,
H PSI equals E PSI.
Don't worry about that.
We'll get to that when we
talk about quantum mechanics
in the second half of the class.
Again, we're not going to
do sort of like quantum 101.
We're going to really talk
about the key essence of quantum
mechanics.
OK?
We're not going to go into great
detail of mathematics of it.
OK, but it's basically
a simple equation
that you need to solve.
So here is that quantum
mechanical ball.
This is just
representing that wave.
Right?
This is a plane wave.
And I'm throwing it into a wall.
And I just happen to put
another wall behind it,
spaced like that, right?
Now, how would you
solve that equation?
What's the first
thing you might try?
Don't say ask Siri.
Actually, you could ask Siri.
Wolfram Alpha Pro is coming out.
So could you put this
in a Mathematica?
Right?
Yeah.
You could, right?
It's an equation.
It's got boundaries.
It's got initial conditions.
And here's what you get, OK.
So that's a quantum
mechanical ball.
It's the simplest
one you could get.
It's just a little shape that
you throw into two walls.
And these are the equations
you have to solve.
Now, the fun part about this,
which the students in this
class two years ago did not
think was that fun when I gave
this on a homework assignment
was that Wolfram Alpha cannot
handle it.
Wolfram, Mathematica, Matlab,
you name it, chokes, right?
You cannot solve these eight
equations and eight unknowns
unless you do some tricks,
and [INAUDIBLE] tricks first.
I won't give another problem
like this, I promise.
But the point of
this was not meant
to drive the students crazy.
That really wasn't the point.
The point was just to illustrate
how hard this equation actually
turns out to be to solve, OK?
It looks simple.
It's deceivingly simple.
We can't solve it even today
without making approximations.
And the only reason we can solve
it today for real materials
is because we've figured out
how to make really important
algorithmic approximations, OK?
The only Nobel Prize given in
computation was given for that.
I think that might
be on my next slide.
And computers have
gotten really fast.
OK, so I'm skipping
ahead of myself.
This is a quote.
So before that,
before we figured out
how to solve that equation
for real materials,
people like Dirac,
really smart people
were feeling a
little bit hopeless.
Right, 1929, "The
underlying physical laws
necessary for the
mathematical theory
of a large part of physics
and the whole of chemistry
are thus completely known."
What's he talking about?
What's completely known?
Yeah, how?
How come?
Right?
They had kind of nailed it.
Right, like in the
late 1800s, they
were like looking at the
world and saying, why?
This doesn't compute.
And then they sort of spent
30 years developing the theory
of quantum mechanics.
And that's why he's saying
it's kind of completely known.
And the difficulty is only
that the exact application
of these laws leads
to equations, much too
complicated to be soluble.
Right?
That was 1929.
He did say later if there's
no complete agreement
between the results of one's
work and the experiment,
one should not allow oneself
to be too discouraged.
I like that quote.
It turns out that happens in
simulation quite a bit, right?
And that has to do with
the fact that you can't
solve the equations exactly.
You have to make approximations.
And knowing where you are
in accuracy phase space
is something that's very
important in this class.
And we'll be talking
about that a lot.
OK?
But don't be discouraged.
Nice words of
encouragement from Dirac.
OK, so that Nobel Prize
I was talking about,
that was actually shared.
But one of the people who
won it was Walter Cohn.
And he won it because
of an approximation,
which I'll talk
about a little bit
when we go into
quantum mechanics.
And it turns out
that you still can't
solve the equations
of quantum mechanics
without making approximations.
Even with the fastest comp--
how many transistors
are on the fastest--
how many transistors can
we put on a chip today?
Does anybody know?
10 billion?
That's a good guess.
I think 3 is where we're at.
And how many neurons
in your brain?
100 billion, right?
So we're getting close.
We're getting real close.
They're catching up, man.
It costs as much money
to make a transistor
on a chip with 3 billion
transistors on it
as it does to print a single
letter in a newspaper.
OK, so we are very good at
printing lots of transistors.
That has dramatically
accelerated how much CPU power
we have.
And it's still worthless,
worthless for the equations
of quantum mechanics, unless
you make simplifications.
So we're going to have to talk
about those simplifications.
Because they're still not
solvable unless you make
these simplifications.
And that's why the Nobel
Prize was given for it.
That's how important it is.
OK?
Once you do that, once
you know the model,
once you develop that model
that Professor Wheeler talked
about for quantum
mechanics, then
you can go ahead
and do simulations.
And you can get some really
interesting properties out.
Like in this case,
this is lead titanate.
And there's some really
interesting magnetic properties
that have to do with
where those electrons are.
So I'm going to just
give you a couple of sort
of motivational slides for why
understanding these electrons
is so important.
OK, and then I'll stop.
How many know what this is?
Yeah.
Quantum dots?
What's happening here?
Why are they different colors?
AUDIENCE: Different
energy bands.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: OK,
and somebody said,
what's the reason for that?
Different sizes.
Isn't that weird?
Why is that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
That's a good try.
Not quite right.
Good guess.
Any other ideas?
Well, there's always the
go to answer, quantum.
It's quantum mechanics.
Right?
This is red and that's blue.
Aqua?
Purple?
I don't know.
Because of quantum
mechanics, right?
Let's break that down.
It has to do with--
this isn't really
breaking that down,
but it's related because
it's nanotechnology.
OK?
So I'm going to explain
that in just a minute.
Nanotechnology.
Well, you all know
about nanotechnology.
The scientist in Spider-Man
was a nanotechnologist.
Did you know that?
And The Incredible Hulk, because
of nanotechnology, right?
So that's how Hollywood
views nanotechnology.
But why am I telling
you about nano?
Well, because the effects
I'm about to describe
is because of nanotechnology.
You hear a lot about
nanotechnology,
and there's a lot
of hype around it.
There's also a lot
of there there, OK?
And I love this, in case you
haven't seen the size scales.
I know you've probably
all seen too much nano.
But I love this one
where you're sitting
on top of some random
dude, and then you go out.
Have you guys seen this?
10 times, 100
times, 1,000, right?
And you keep going
out, OK, and that's
how far you are when you
go out by 10 to the 9th.
And then you start again and
you go in by the same amount,
right?
And so that's sort of
just trying to give you
a sense of the scales, right?
So that's nano is going in by
the same amount you'd be going
out to get to here, right?
It's kind of cool.
It's small stuff.
Why is that interesting?
Oh, the press seems to know.
It's because super
cows and nanotechnology
will make ice cream healthy.
That's actually still
my favorite article
about nanotechnology.
It's about healthy ice cream.
Actually, my favorite part
of this is the definition.
I love this definition.
It is also experimenting with
nanotechnology or the science
of invisibly tiny things.
Right?
We just saw them.
They're red and blue.
They're not invisible.
OK, right, I highlighted it.
OK, back to that example, right?
So why am I
connecting nano here?
Well, because quantum
feels nano a lot.
Quantum and nano very
often go hand in hand.
Now, it depends
how nano you mean.
Some people say they're
working on nano,
and they're really
at like 0.8 microns.
That's sort of cheating, right?
But not really.
Hey, this is like some
millions of nanometers.
I guess that's working on nano.
If I take a bulk semiconductor,
what's a semiconductor?
It's this picture.
Somebody give me an example
of a semiconductor material.
AUDIENCE: Silicon?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Silicon.
Right?
What are the properties
of a semiconductor.
Somebody tell me one
property of a semiconductor.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah, yeah.
It's got a gap.
Not too big, not too
small, just right.
OK?
We'll be coming
back to that a lot,
because that gap is
something you can predict
using quantum mechanics.
You have to have quantum
mechanics to predict it.
Now, it turns out that if I
look at this piece of silicon,
it's optically not
that exciting, right?
That will go along with
those different colors.
Right, it just sort
of looks like charcoal
actually, unless you process it.
Might be a little shiny,
but it's kind of boring.
If I take out my little
nano ice cream scooper--
I'm a theorist, right?
So this is how I
view experiments.
And you now scoop out
a little piece of it.
We have a name for that.
That's called the
quantum dot, right?
That's a quantum dot.
But it's nothing more
than a little tiny piece.
It's a nano piece, right?
What happens?
What happens is if you do
that, that's when you get this.
Right?
Why?
Back to our-- you know
what the answer is.
Quantum mechanics, OK?
Here's the reason.
Something called
quantum confinement, OK?
It turns out that if I
create an optical excitation
in this bulk
semiconductor-- let's
say I shine a laser on it.
That's about the worst
PowerPoint graphic
I've ever seen.
Anyway, but it's a laser.
And you shine a light on it.
Well, happens is, you
see these little objects
that I said were very quantum
mechanical, the electron.
Right?
What happens is the
energy from the light
kicks an electron out of
what's called its ground state.
Well, we're going
to talk about that.
I'm getting really
excited myself.
And when it gets kicked
out of its ground state
it leaves behind a hole,
or a positive charge, OK?
So now you've got
a negative charge
and a positive charge that have
been made in this material.
They've been made by light.
Why might I be
excited about that?
No pun intended [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you, one person.
If you've suffered through me
last fall then, you know it.
So why might I be
excited about that?
AUDIENCE: Solar power?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Thank you.
Solar power!
We just made electricity
from sunlight.
Now, it turns out that electron,
that positive and negative
charge like to be a
certain distance apart.
Right, and bulk
silicon, 5 nanometers.
Right, it's called
the exciton radius.
When you create an
electron hole pair,
they kind of like each other.
Well, they're very
weakly bound in silicon.
But they have a distance
that they like to hang out,
in this case 5 nanometers.
And what that means
is that when I run out
of real estate in the material,
and I do the same thing,
well, they don't
have anywhere to be.
They want to be
out here, but they
can't be, because there's
no material out there.
Right, so if I'm less
than that exciton radius,
then my excitation is squeezed.
We have a name for that.
It's actually called
quantum confinement.
Why?
Because these are very
quantum mechanical objects.
You need quantum mechanics
to describe them.
And what you've done is
you've squeezed them.
You've increased
their kinetic energy.
And that is the reason
the color changes.
That's the reason
the band gap changes.
And so you can see that
the physical confinement
of this excited state leads
to this very unique quantum
effect, which is that the light
emitted depends on size, right?
One example of many, of
sort of the beauty that
comes from understanding
the quantum
mechanics, and we're going
to be able to simulate
this in the second
part of this class.
OK?
Now, that is a really
useful piece of technology.
Quantum dots are being used--
does anybody know about
the uses of quantum dots?
I mean, they're already
in companies, right?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Solar cells.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Solar cells, right?
LED TVs, biomarkers.
It's big in the biotech.
Oh, sorry.
I just stole your answer.
And I didn't want to do that.
Any other ideas?
They're really useful, right?
And they're getting
more and more useful.
Very interesting, all
quantum mechanics.
That gets me really excited,
because I work on energy.
And I'm not going to do an
energy talk, don't worry.
But I work a lot on energy.
And the fact of the matter is
that this is a map of the US.
And it shows where there's
good to excellent resources
in some renewable technologies,
like PV, red and orange.
Biomass, green and light green.
Wind.
Number one most
utilized renewable
resource in the world
today is wind, right?
So if you look at this,
there's only a few pockets
where you're sort of--
sorry, man, it's gas or oil.
Now, but we don't use hardly
any of these resources, right?
And the reason, as we all
know, is cost and efficiency.
But in so many of these
technologies, not wind,
in this case, but PV,
biomass, and in a number
of other technologies,
solar fuels,
the key is pushing
electrons around.
That's the key.
It's pushing electrons up a
hill, and letting the electrons
fall down a hill, right?
I mean, one of the oldest
ways to store energy is what?
Who knows?
It goes way back.
Still really used around
the world, including the US.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Steam.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Steam is a way.
That's true.
Think older.
Pumping water.
Who said that?
In the back.
Pumping water.
You pump water up a hill.
You hold it in a big lake.
And you let it come down
when you need energy, right?
You pump it up when
you have the energy,
and let it come
down when you need
it is a terribly inefficient way
to store energy, but it works.
And basically, what we need to
do for so many of these energy
technologies is figure out
how to more efficiently pump
electrons up a hill.
That's basically what
we're doing, right?
And that's quantum mechanics.
Because by definition,
electrons need quantum mechanics
to describe.
Right?
So we're going to pump
electrons up hills and around
in the second part
of this class.
And you can tell
your friends that.
And it will impress
them, I promise you.
I always like to help
you make conversation
when you're at the bar.
Because here's a solar cell.
Do I have any time left?
Yeah, I got a couple minutes.
I'm almost done.
I'm really almost done.
Cause we're going to
work on solar cells.
First, we're going to spend
sort of the first half
of the quantum part
learning about quantum,
and how to simulate
that equation, right?
We're going to do simulations.
And then we're going to
apply those simulation
tools to real problems.
So we're going to study
solar cells, for one.
And look at this.
Here is how a solar cells works.
Well, that's what you see if
you take like a core six class,
and if you think about
it from the device scale.
But here's what's happening
inside that solar cell.
Sunlight comes in.
Squiggly lines are
always sunlight, right?
Squiggly line comes in.
And there is that electron.
You can tell.
Actually, you can't.
But there it is.
And it gets promoted
up, cause that light
has energy with it that knocks
this electron up an energy.
And look at what it left behind.
A hole, just like I showed
you in silicon, right?
In those quantum dots.
But in a solar cell, you don't
want them to recombine and emit
light.
You don't want them to
shine different colors.
In a solar cell, you want
to get those charges out.
You want to get that
electron out of one side,
and get that hole out of
the other side, right?
Every single step here,
converting the photon
into an electron, electron
and hole thermalize.
They couple to the
solar cell, and they
waste all that energy coming
back up to the valence
and conduction band.
They wasted all
this heat, right?
The electron hole pair diffuses.
Hello there.
Welcome to 302-1.
This thing can move around.
This pair can move around.
And
Then you've got to
get them apart, right?
And you got to get
them out, right?
Every single step
that's critical
is a quantum mechanical step.
Right, you cannot describe these
processes unless you can solve
Schrodinger's equation, OK?
So we'll be talking
about that and how
to make solar cells better.
For example, in silicon,
people put charts like this up.
More than 80% of the solar
cells you buy today are this.
They're multi crystalline
silicon, right?
Now, the solar cells
in your calculators
are amorphous silicon.
And the reason
is, they're cheap.
They're very cheap.
But they're very inefficient.
And so you see things-- but
they could be thin and flexible.
That's kind of nice.
But they're just
not that efficient.
And so you start
seeing things like,
well, here, let's compare
these two crystals.
Here's a crystalline.
Here's amorphous.
There's a gap.
Difference in
energy between those
states that the electron gets
excited to, very different.
There's absorption coefficients.
Very different.
There's mobilities.
And this is actually
what kills it.
Those holes are so slow.
Right?
Well, how can you
compute those things?
Let me hear it.
AUDIENCE: Quantum.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Thank
you, quantum mechanics.
We can calculate, and we
will calculate these things
for these kinds of materials.
And maybe you'll find a way
to make amorphous silicon have
faster holes.
And if you do that,
please come talk to me.
[LAUGHTER]
I'd be really interested,
because I've been working
on that problem for many years.
But these are the
kinds of things we're
going to do, OK, in this class.
And I'll tell you
one quick story.
I was at a conference
on solar energy.
And they gave out
calculators as kind
of solar powered calculators,
solar energy calculators.
Solar energy conference,
solar powered calculators.
And we opened one up.
And it turned out it
was battery powered.
[LAUGHTER]
And there was a little piece
of amorphous silicon solar cell
in there, but it
wasn't wired up.
And the reason is, these are
so poor in their efficiencies,
right?
We've all seen it.
You need to be in direct sun.
And you can't see it anymore.
Right?
Why?
If we could figure out how
to boost that whole mobility,
we could get their
efficiencies up.
They'd cost a lot less.
We'd make a game
changing difference.
So these are the
kinds of problems
that we're going to work
on in the second half.